welcome to a very special edition of a
beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
comer and so last week we had a video
about the two nights the fence and it
seems like people still aren't convinced
that this opening is terrible for
beginners all right so let's check out a
comment let's swing it over to the
comment section all right we have one
mr. Jared plain Mike comer expresses his
belief that the two nice defense is a
forced win for white by repeatedly
showing games by players that barely
know how the pieces even move great
times
content is always Mike all right we'll
just leave it at that the great content
okay but it goes on blah blah blah blah
blah blah so so then you look you look
at this guy
Jared plain you click on them everybody
knows of course what the worst music
genre is of all time right Jess yeah
don't be dumping so convinced about it
yeah so jazz so so you see this guy he
likes the you know singing like
polka-dots and moonbeams and stuff so do
maybe you should get your own house in
order before you start critiquing chess
videos alright so here we go and for
once and for all
we will show you the fried liver again
and this is from this Friday night ok
it's funny how when you're playing black
again in this two nights defense that
kids aren't running down showing their
games I'll look at this I 1 in 11 moves
it's always the player playing white and
sides that's very very weird right
alright so here we go so andrew is
playing white against an all
gentleman he's been playing for a long
time and the older gentleman's rating is
950
okay sorry here we go time control is
game 20 with a three-second delay friday
action quiet so we all know how this is
gonna play out Bishop c4 Knight f6 and
of course what move should White's lamb
here 995 wait
yeah just slam it and it's like alright
here we go
d5 he takes and now he's like I'm gonna
let the fried liver happen okay I'm not
playing Knight a5 because we all see how
that works out anyway right so it just
take the pawn okay alright so obviously
fried liver you capture the pawn and
slam it alright alright so so your queen
and rook are both Forks so the King has
to take the knight
all right and now you get a big Shaq so
now two players are attacking the knight
and we only have one defender so that
you think the King really wants to be
out here on move you know six seven no
all right so so now the night is up in a
pen whenever a knight is in a pen it's a
stuck piece meaning it can't move so you
should attack the pinned pieces
especially when it's the night so who
can help out attack the knight here any
guesses how about this knight on c3 okay
and now so now the way black would
defend in this position is either by
playing Knight to b4 and their night to
be four so he's threatening to check and
also getting c6 in to solidify his
position as much as he possibly
can okay but instead he's like I'm gonna
attack your queen big mistake right
big mistake so what move should white
play here he's got two good moves well
no he's just got one so you better get
it right
checks are always good right no no no
you don't want to you don't want to let
them off the hook though so who should
take who's the other guy that can take
that would deliver the check don't fish
bishop check he's like all right
whatever I just I just try to get back
to Iain be safe it's like no you ain't
going back to a buddy
it's like okay I just find her out in
the middle of the board some more let's
see how it's yeah it really works out
for them all right so does everybody see
the checkmate here
well how about Knight to e4 Knight to d5
looks b5 b5 was oh there's a big
difference between Knight to b5 check
and Knight to e4 check big difference
one we can capture it - that's not
checkmate
the great thing about Knight to e4 is it
covers this up pivotal c5 square so
that's actually checkmate guys alright
so now yeah you see a lot of kids
running down after their victory wow I
beat him in 12 moves I didn't know chess
was so easy right
but yeah I said you know the player
playing black never does he's always got
a sad look on his face was like why do I
play the worst why do my teachers tell
me to to get annihilated in five moves
all the time but alright so you could be
saying like other commentators well you
haven't seen the Traxler variation well
guess what we have seen it we've gone
over it check out the
2015 SummerSlam bash the only kid that
still plays the Traxler is of course
Harper Evan Smith student okay so we'll
just go over the Traxler very quickly
because that's all it it deserves so
it's like I tricked you
I tricked you it's like you didn't trick
nobody
alright so Bishop takes pawn check this
is the pivotal position in the Traxler
all right so obviously we have three
potential moves here we could play like
the people in the fried liver and bring
our King out to the center okay we could
just move our King to f1 or we could
take and get crushed crushed Knight
takes crush okay so we're just we're
just calmly moved to f1 and now we're up
by a thousand points free rook and he's
got nothing right you try to come down
and take or if he takes you know we got
this big check where we take take check
King moves and then point all right so
we have so much we have the people
playing Trexler have nothing as long as
you don't take the bishop got it and
then we're the winners all right sound
good we're winners yeah all right so so
all right so I don't want to hear
anything about the Traxler anymore
yeah all right so now so now the final
the final criticism here all right oh
hey oh yeah
it's it's somebody that used to be one
of my biggest supporters alright so so
here it is hey Mike bla bla bla
okay it's something you teach it's not
that simple but have you ever checked it
in Grandmaster level games alright the
answer is yes alright and here it is for
you rose buster okay hopefully you'll be
back on my side alright here we go so we
have a game
from the US Chess Championship between
he Cora Nakamura spoiler alert he was
the US chess champion this year because
of this game instead of our good friend
over here and he played mr. Josh Videla
a good player in his own right okay so
here we go efore 'if I've Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop c4 so so Josh freed L
probably thought there's no way he's
gonna play you know Knight g5 on me and
everything will be okay okay so he's
probably really hoping before he played
that move and then there's worst
nightmare happen okay Nakamura slams the
he's gay I'm going for the championship
buddy and so here it is alright alright
so d5 pawn takes okay so notice he's
like okay you're not getting the fried
liver with me so - nice defense
so Bishop c4 check c6 pawn takes pawn
takes and now Nakamura plays the
suggested move Bishop to d3 as you saw I
played that against the national master
of quran huh okay Bishop d3 it's a great
move okay it totally just debunks the
whole thing and so now let's take
another great look at blacks structure
here his knight useless pawn isolated
another pawn isolated but hey you know
you've got the initiative somehow I
guess cuz it's your move this is how you
have the initiative and let's see let's
see your big initiative move right all
right more discovered attacks on the
night great all right so all right
Nakamura I'll get developed excellent
I'll castle okay a castle rook b8
alright get some pressure on the B file
and so it's like alright I'm not gonna
let you attack me with h3 great great
Macklemore aged 3 I love it love it love
it love c5 ok so now what is blacks
threat here he just pushed this pawn
from c6 the c5 you better get this right
yeah push it up again yeah yeah yeah
it's a really really intense threat
there okay so Nakamura
you know plays b3 if I would have played
be three against Koran Han I'd have 50
more bucks on my pocket right now but uh
all right so all right so now he's like
alright I'll get my rook out there all
right so I don't know about that move
all right so a Nakamura is like I out
develop normal rook e1
all right so Bishop b7 I like it I like
it all right so now he's targeting some
squares Nakamura scamp okay so it's okay
so so good good a good idea by uh by
Josh Vidal there okay so he's got his
bishop along an act of diagonal since he
couldn't do anything on this other
diagonal so that was good that was good
but Nakamura is like I can have a my
Bishop on a good day to look out for so
so this is pretty dangerous rooks are
pretty much you know long-range pieces
really work better vertically unless
they're like on the seventh rank or
conversely on the second rank when you
have a rook on the fifth fourth third
ranked sixth rank just ask him it to get
attacked and captured right so all right
here we go yep attack it right all right
rook d4 Knight up three just can't stand
the pressure now he's like man my rook
made so many bogus moves well nobody
told you to put on before in the first
place buddy but alright so so he's like
I just so sick of it I just get rid of
this rook alright so he sacrifices the
exchange so what else could nope here
done okay done and I give you a hint the
knight is attacking rook so if he didn't
want his rook harassed by the knight
anymore what could it be played
well yeah he could have moved it back
but you know yeah the Brooks had a
maximum amount of moving for the game
he's worn out
how about removed the attacker right
and now the rook is no longer her rest
okay buddies like I forget it just all
right so there so all right the bishops
gone and now he's got Queen takes pawn
so so he's getting someplace all right
all right so he says but white can win a
pawn right back
hi Martin my great friend Martin he is
back mmm you don't want to take that
pawn because uh because you know it's
protected hey Martin knows which pawn
can white take here and with which piece
Knight yes knight Knight takes all right
so now he's got to move his queen so
guess what Nakamura can just attack it
again so again so he goes back d4 and
now josh is like I'm gonna pin that pawn
all right so he pinned it so Nakamura is
like okay I'll just move as I go it's as
simple as that and now Josh Greedo he's
got three different ways to take a pawn
spoiler alert he'll take the worst
possible way it's tough to be a
grandmaster so many choices so many
choices so yeah you could take with the
rook now you're thinking like Josh
Friedel
yeah Queen or pawn obviously take what
the pawn could get interesting could get
interesting
so the Bishop's hanging but your Knights
hanging but not good because then your
Brooks hanging oh so that choice should
have been pretty easy down lemonade okay
so so now you're down to two choices
yeah do you have don't like that choice
yeah I get it get it out of the get it
out of the mind we're not taking with
the pawn okay good alright so now we
have the rook or the Queen rook all
right all right
rook it is all right rook it is rook it
is that's what Joshua Doyle thought now
he failed to see a crusher her crusher
so I want everybody that the think for a
minute you can play like Nakamura and
win the US Chess Championship if you can
find this great move and by the way you
should take a good look at this Knight
over here too he's really doing great it
really doesn't great he's got his
isolated pawn still no no I want
everybody to really think I want
everybody get this alright well we got
one we think it's got to be a really
good move I mean really good even better
than moves like Knight f3 cuz that's
just horrible so I so it's got to be
better than that right a white to move
and crush and win the championship and
I'm sure he won like 40,000 bucks or so
for winning the championship and got his
name engraved on a on a beautiful trophy
it's tough to see a lot of a lot of
blacks pieces are just like totally
misplaced I mean just totally obviously
the night this bishops not doing much
this rook is in the center this queen is
in you know the camp but you know
doesn't really have too many spaces to
go
does she it's not a knight move okay
look look an easy way look when you're
when you're trying to calculate out
checks and captures right you just need
to be looking at every single one of
them right so so how many pieces can
possibly even attack the Queen right the
knight can but he'll get eaten right
this knight can but they'll get eaten
this knight can but they can get eaten
so it's not the knife so who else we got
that can attack the Queen Oh [ __ ] up
the we know what you mean right
fish up to see one babies no see bishop
to see one right see ones good and now
you got that one Martin good and now the
Queen's got no place to go because
you're attacking her flight squares as
well so his us chess champion so I'm
sure you know you play the - nice
defense you get what you deserve
thank you very much